hey guys what's up I'm Alana and today
I'm playing battlefield hardline so this
is the rescue mode that we're playing
right now one of my favorite game modes
so far where I have to go rescue the
hostage just makes sense right rescue
you would think Phoebe rescue the
hostage anyway so obviously i'm on a
team of cops does it know the team out
here somewhere I've been doing pretty
well playing this today so far so
weirdly enough in most games that seem
to be the leadership freaking touchy no
I did not want to leave Wow sometimes
Eileen works and sometimes it does
that's really annoying especially when
I'm trying to actually be stuffy but
yeah some people just seem to play this
by like running out and just going for
it and I really don't understand why you
would do that when you have an objective
right like this would be a lot easier if
we could talk to each other there's this
guy doing what you go in is there
anything even out here well I wish I
could lead and have okay if it did work
know that what I could go out there but
why why would I do why would even go out
that people like don't seem to actually
pay attention to the objectives which
confuses the crap out of me but I can't
talk to them to get angry at them over
the microphone so I'm just gonna get
angry at them on my lonesome here uh all
right so that one's really close to me
that guy out there teach get shot at I'm
sure it probably did but like I mean the
criminals right now should be guarding
the hostages but every time I played
this so far there's only one map where
they seem to because they spawned me
them here zero like maybe that there's
no one in here there's no one in this
room at all I can just take this guy and
go haven't even seen anyone yet like
girl stupid but I do think that this is
a great game mode I think it's gonna be
really really competitive when it
actually goes online right now I'm
playing in a giant room full of people
which isn't quite the same as playing it
competitively online and and this is not
going to be exciting if I just run the
hell out of here I didn't did a really
interesting last game but I didn't know
[ __ ] no no no no no I'll be fine his I'm
sorry yeah my last game was really
exciting but I wasn't recording quality
put so it couldn't upload it but alright
this is since you seem like one person
oh my god what I do know oh my god nor
[ __ ] kidding me oh my god
I mean while it's really easy oh my god
you will 88 Ilana so this one is krauser
welcome back I'm playing as a VIP this
is my first time playing as a VIP so
this mode is basically where one person
is an important person and the police
have to I to protect them or yeah the
police have to try and protect them bad
guys have to try and kill them you can
win the mode by killing all the police
if you're a criminal or by killing the
VIP and my goal here as the VIP is to
get through without being killed I
suppose I have to go to the other side
which is where the bad guys spoon um I
mean this guy seems like he knows what
he's doing so let's just join him shall
we yeah why is he shooting in there like
that doesn't its opening that and
drawing attention to yourself when I'm
right here seems like a terrible idea I
think that you should probably not do
that just crawling alone doop de doop to
do did you do he's dumping shut up
you're good can you like to check it
amazing yeah go fast that seems like a
good idea the second video that I've got
audio for it and i have not had any
combat on how to upload another video
worry about cough Adam may be in one of
the later game words for these
competitive ones you know it's I've been
in positions it's better to weed it
what's the bar I'm even to make this I
mean I have no health but i think i'm
gonna make it look at it I made it oh my
god that was too easy you're all
terrible so that was it for my time with
battlefield hardline I've got one more
that I recorded audio for that i will
upload as soon as possible which is
blood money which is a little bit longer
so I'm Ilana thank you guys for watching
and I will see you next time okay